Since the conference app doesn't use touch that much, we're
going to have you take a look at adding touch support
to a different example. Let's take a look at how we
would code a simple drawing application on a web page. First,
let's look at this, as we would write it for the
mouse. You can see where we've hooked the mouse down, mouse
move and mouse up events. And you can see are handlers
for each one of these simply creates a new stroke and
the adds points to that stroke as we go.
Now, we'd like you to change this code to use
pointer events. Don't forget to set the touch action attribute
on the HTML element that you're using as an event
listener. We've already included the polymer polyfill, so you
don't need to worry about doing that. Just change the
event handlers to be pointer events and then make any
appropriate changes to the handlers themselves if there are any.